on this international day of persons
with disabilities we are taking a moment
to mark and celebrate the world's
biggest minority group about 15 of the
global population that's about 1 billion
people are classified as disabled
persons according to the world health
organization that's right scarlet and
that figure is rising steadily as a
result of population growth and medical
advances disabled people are living long
healthy lives working and of course
contributing to all parts of society but
there's still a big gap in tech advances
that allow better access to everyday
things like the internet our next guest
is a lawyer philanthropist and advocate
for persons with disabilities josh basil
is the community relations manager for
accessibility it's a group making the
internet more accessible to everyone and
josh is also a disabled person living
strongly as a c45 quadriplegic josh
welcome to quick take scarlet and i are
really excited to unpack this briefly
explain to us how the internet is
inaccessible to people living with
disabilities
madison and scholar it's great to be
here today
so with the internet there's many layers
to making a website accessible
and basically when you're on a site you
have to experience it in a certain way
whether it's navigating
from the the drop down menus to
accessing pictures to the text
you name it so
what
one of the things that people don't
really know about the internet is less
than two percent of websites on the
internet actually meet accessibility
guidelines to allow persons with
disabilities to fully access websites
just like everyone else
so let's back up for a moment here josh
because it's important that we're not
only talking about people with visible
disabilities there's clearly a lot of
disabilities that are not overt that you
can't see with the naked eye so can you
clarify for us and give us a sense of
some of the invisible disabilities and
what that entails
so with invisible disabilities there's
persons with cognitive disabilities
there's there's persons with epilepsy
that if you have a light or a thing
that's blinking it can trigger the event
for somebody that goes on your website
um i'm i'm a quadriplegic i'm paralyzed
below my shoulders so a lot of times
like even doing an interview like this
today you have no idea that i'm in a
power wheelchair at the moment but
that i i operate my wheelchair with
with different technologies i operate my
computer with different technologies and
that's that's how i'm able to access the
world
what's the biggest contributor to this
problem i'm curious is it a tech problem
we don't have the innovation there is it
a willingness to spend to make these
websites more accessible and inclusive
or is it a diversity issue for the
people building the website where does
the problem lie
so the problem lies a lot of the times
and
over over history it's been just a lack
of awareness people just don't even know
that their websites are inaccessible and
like with the company that i work with
accessibility uh we have accessory.com
ace you can go put your website in and
it can test do an audit and let you know
where you're succeeding and where you're
not and that's that's one big thing is
about awareness other things over the
years
technology just hasn't been there yet
and basically the only way to actually
make a website accessible was through
manual coding
going through each line every page and
but as technology has advanced we now
have ai-powered solutions that can come
in and help do so much of what used to
only be done by hand
yeah i think that's an important point
especially as we continue to make uh new
technology more accessible i wonder
we talk a lot about the likes of
facebook now meta
it's tempting to and easy to blame a
company like facebook um
and the responsibilities that big tech
companies
face and bear for perhaps not making
their platforms as accessible as they
could be
how much do you think they deserve the
scrutiny especially as they build out
new worlds like the metaverse
so as they build out new worlds that's a
very important point you just made there
so what's what's wrong and what's been
really difficult as time go on and it's
especially true with the internet itself
persons with disabilities will not we're
not really invited to have a seat at the
table in the beginning days and as it
grew less and less accessible it become
basically persons with disabilities
became an afterthought and with
diversity equity inclusion being put
more into corporations all across the
world people are talking about uh making
sure that that diversity equity and
inclusion really is has a part within
the business world we're starting to
have better conversations so if the
metaverse is built and persons with
disabilities persons with diversity
are not
included then we're going to have a huge
problem but if they are included from
the beginning then we can do this right
and
we're not going to have the same problem
of having less than two percent of the
net being accessible uh i'm excited
about the metaverse it's it makes me
think about like ready player one and
being able to like really immerse
yourself in a new
kind of world of however you want to
draw up that reality which really really
excites me but i
just love to be a part of it from the
beginning and and so if that's the case
and i know video game companies are kind
of at the forefront of all this how are
the activation blizzards or the road
boxes which are platforms of course are
they leaders or are they followers in
this regard
um
i don't know if i want to speak to those
unique companies but it's just
i know we all can do better and what it
takes is making sure that persons with
disabilities are hired within your
businesses
giving them a seat at the table hearing
their unique perspectives persons with
disabilities are so
they're have so many talents so many
skills they're natural problem solvers
every single day we have to overcome
barriers so i just i love the idea of
having these type of corporations bring
in more people that have expertise in
this area bringing in more consultants
but making sure that you do it right
from the beginning and if you do that
you start creating a disability
inclusion culture where it's ingrained
within the corporation's dna and like i
said before it then doesn't become an
afterthought
you know we started this conversation
with the statistic that disabled people
are the world's largest minority group
making up 15 of the global population
that's a huge chunk of individuals to
not have access equitable access to
something as
big as the internet obviously you know
why are we still not doing enough to
include and center differently abled
people particularly uh in the workplace
well first of all
by you guys today having this
conversation you're doing so much good
to make sure that we bring this
awareness to the world and then when it
comes to employment the trouble is is
that if you don't have people within the
employment world
with disabilities you're not you're not
hearing from them you're not seeing them
you're not
having their ability for them to
contribute especially at all levels
whether it's at the lower level of a
company or upper management as as
someone rises in their career so the
more people that we have with
disabilities within all parts of of of
life we're going to see so much of a
different world we're gonna have
different conversations and um the
persons with disabilities right now are
the most unemployed and underemployed
population in the entire world they've
been really excluded they haven't been
there hasn't been an inclusive hiring
process within most businesses they just
they haven't taken the time to learn
kind of what what it is and what it what
you can do to better hire and find
talent within the disability community
right right and as i'm hearing you talk
about that it's clear that you know it's
a diverse community it's not a monolith
of course but i am curious if you see
any big overarching theme for for the
biggest thing that employers get wrong
about serving their disabled employees
you know when we think about ada
guidelines we maybe think about
something like ramps or things like that
infrastructure is there uh any other
kind of pushes that would be better for
employers or in addition for employers
to focus on
so the big thing is to not make
assumptions so a lot of times you would
look at me
i'm paralyzed i have a power wheelchair
obviously you can't see it right now but
you'd think i'm very limited in certain
things that i can do
like through technology through
all these different things that are
available to me allow me to get my mind
my voice into the world i graduated
magna [ __ ] laude from law school without
ever flipping a page with my fingers
a lot of people probably didn't think
that would be possible but it's like
it's just understanding that
not to assume somebody can or cannot do
something give them opportunity have the
right conversation and you know you're
going to see incredible things happen
within your corporation and i think so
many small businesses just need to look
look at all your employees do you have
to do you have diversity do you have
disability making up all facets of your
business and then even with small
businesses making sure that getting your
website successful like accessory
provides an ai powered solution that
allows you to do it and it's it's
incredible to be able to bring these
type of technologies that can then scale
it from that two percent to five percent
the 50 of the internet which i cannot
wait for the day without the internet's
more accessible to people
i think that's a beautiful place to
leave it josh really appreciate you
joining us and sharing all of that
information thank you so much josh basil
is an activist for the disabled and
community as a whole and community
relations manager for accessibility